imaginez-vous xiième siècle sur une
ancienne villa gallo-romaine l'abbaye de
fond morinie se construit pendant huit
siècles les moines cisterciens tire
parti de ressources de ce paysage dont
le minerai de fer exploiter
artisanalement pour fabriquer des outils
abandonné fin 19ème siècle le domaine
tombe en ruine
dominique et sa compagne claude restant
l'abbaye depuis 30 ans amoureux du lieu
ils en connaissent toute l'histoire il
ya tous les ingrédients pour qu'il y ait
une vie humaine il ya de l'eau des prêts
des bois et on est dans une sorte de
petite vallée
dans un fonds de vallée c'est un passage
et sa appel à la vie évidemment surtout
dans l'économie agraire qu'on a connus
ces deux derniers millénaires
l'intérêt de ces lieux ce qui est tous
les siècles la tour qui est en-avant
correspond au 14e siècle ensuite le set
pointe avec l'escalier correspond au 16e
ensuite l'intérieur du réfectoire
correspond au 12e il y avait un cellier
qui refermait cette cour mais qui depuis
a disparu et vous avez une église du 12e
avec une entrée une architecture
classique c'est le début du 18e et c'est
vraiment un architecte du xviie qu'il a
fait c'est le grand siècle
au coeur du domaine et de la vie des
moines un bâtiment majeur l'église
abbatiale sobre et dépouillée cette fois
par jour la communauté monastique s'ils
recueillent et chante
tout doit aider à la spiritualité et
l'église abbatiale a été volontairement
imaginer comme devant être simple donc
effectivement le moine quand il prit ici
dans les deux premières travail vous
voyez là et dans une atmosphère dans un
paysage je crois que le mot est
parfaitement adapté à ce type de
bâtiment très fonctionnel et qui doit
aider encore une fois à remplir cette
tâche communiquez avec ce qu'ils pensent
être dur
l'abbaye restera un lieu monastique
jusqu'au xviiie siècle ses activités
agricoles et de forges ont façonné le
paysage est initié l'activité
sidérurgique industrielle du val
d'aubois tout proche vendue comme bien
national à la révolution elle est
transformée en exploitation agricole et
sert de dortoir aux 300 ouvriers
métallurgiques des forges de torteron ça
c'est la marque du 19e siècle et c'est
difficile de s'imaginer mais à la fin du
xviiie ci avec le moment où les moines
sont chassées en 1796 il reste sept
moines et le siècle suivant il ya plus
de 300 personnes qui sont là mais il
faut imaginer un endroit polluer avec
l'industrie de faire le metalurgi
partout
l'abbaye change de paysage ses murs de
pierres se pare de briques les viviers
servant à l'élevage des alevins pour
ensemencer les étangs sont transformés
pour alimenter les forges distance de 2
km
c'est une force c'est une énergie
motrice ce simplement on a besoin d'une
eau à certains rites c'est pour ça que
vous avez un pont qui avec un effet
venturi avec une face droite et une
phase plus en billets qui permet
d'accélérer l'eau pour le faire tourner
des moulins qui vont permettre de faire
du faire enfin deux pattes le faire
début du 20e siècle la lorraine découvre
le charbon développent ces forges font
régner déserté
aujourd'hui le travail de restauration
permet de valoriser l'action des moines
cisterciens
en europe avec près de 2000 monastère et
abbayes ses bâtisseurs ont aussi été de
grands aménageurs de nos paysages
oh